hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay if you're
observant you might notice that there's
something in the corner of my screen
it's a new microphone it's a blue Yeti
USB desktop microphone very very good
microphone my other one crapped out on
me
so I screamed into it too much and it
just exploded yeah that's what happened
anyway
what we got going on here is besides a
little lag we got um we got get what do
we get a beacon what if I taught myself
I've taught myself a million times to
check dead bodies I'm stupid oh and also
we got a level-4 soup schematic hey
microphone calm down there this thing is
big
I think it's beefy as hell I've got a
elevator access to the my donut deck it
was a security lockdown although I don't
think it helped them oh now that you've
got the beacon and the key head over
there yeah just a minute
yeah asteroid is held in place by some
gravity tethers yes sir job to knock
those out before you can launch it oh
whatever
I'm gonna get my suit this is the first
video that I've recorded with a new
microphone and hopefully my voice sounds
a little better if not I'm still
tweaking settings I haven't found
exactly what I need to do yet but
hopefully hopefully I'll get it soon
enough any baddies want to jump down on
me didn't think so yeah
but I mean this thing is massive it's at
least twice as big if not more than my
other microphone obviously it's high
enough that it's starting to cut into
the frame but that's okay
you can still see my beautiful face I
was a story yeah boy let's get it oh I'm
ready ready for a new suit
come on level four suit oh yeah only
35,000 touched chump change to me
yep step into the Machine oh death
spectral horrors from another dimension
more inventory space yeah
so that broom handle move there we go so
we've got armor and both arms now all
right Isaac looking good
ooh and more armor on the back cuz
enemies like us sneaking up and take you
from behind not in a dirty way your mind
out of the gutter all right I don't need
to large as obviously don't need two
mediums either [ __ ] ya here not here get
out of here okay no no no Cobb - ah get
back here
contact him there we go I don't know
what these little random spurts of lack
I'm sorry about that
hopefully it won't be that big of a deal
you seem to give me getting smooth her
frame rates now there yes there we go
okay yeah I don't have antivirus running
in the background some and I hardly have
any other programs running so it
shouldn't be a problem for must moment
mining that's horrible going right I
think that was the only one that was
great out so I imagine that is the only
left to go to I don't know who knows
these things
who's out there are you some clean
clanging someone want to step no one
that's what I thought
alright see what other side
ah back off who's out there I'm coming
for you
oh hey
no it will big to loud in my headphones
hopefully it's good for you guys those
guys weren't nothing
this body parts wait note its arms in a
circle that supposed to be a symbol for
something where am I going where leave
good wait what like I went nowhere keep
going down okay
okay I need to find up a battery I think
big battery yeah I think it's a big
oh there's a hands in a sir I get it
safety is in his hands maybe that's not
something haha oh no too late oh alright
okay got a bench and here's a battery
wait just power to something else
power up bucks oh stop the crap out of
you guys anymore in there
No
yeah don't even try it little creepy
guys okay
what's up here first and I need to find
out before I go disabling the power to
anything else
oh no Mon I got OD what that oh my Nikki
oh I got the key
okay I got it I got it all taken care
wha so you move don't trust you moosh
lose oh hello what's that no parent up
yeah me Dad
there's a bench right down sir don't
trust you yes nope
you're - yeah no don't trust any of you
oh my tums point boy I'm get here
asteroid release tethers must be the
activate okay um um okay that must be
why I needed to get the battery into the
other so I could go deactivate the
tethers then I come up here okay okay
we're good we're good
yeah my big blue Yeti here
I love this microphone just got it today
so nice I don't care if people call you
fat Yeti I love this
let me go the bench here tonight I don't
know what else that I have to upgrade I
mean besides maybe this guess nah I'm
good on health
I don't need air ah I guess all good the
stasis what I go for energy or duration
I'll go for dirt
why not some dirt up in her all right no
there's a store right there that's
convenient
I can I can get nope don't no no no oh
not fair man not cool bro
whoa anymore one tangle with me yeah you
could have never mind
ah what was that something more like
nothing I go so slow
a little more speed walk you over there
that's the safe one real quick all right
here boy put on and let me touch the
store who goodies audio log lag what the
heck
supervisor second engineer Dallas
reporting well you got to be kidding me
lag now my last report I I'm really
sorry guys I don't know why my
computer's lagging all this time it's
been fine I can't let that happen to me
at least if I don't have any limbs I
won't be able to kill anyone when I'm
infected
yeah please tell Don yeah and the kids
that I love them oh okay
that guy just cut his own limbs off with
a gun I don't know oh the plasma cutter
of course I'm an idiot all right
whatever
I just I just went to the store I don't
own a movie but I don't need why I know
I don't know why I need to go again
I what getting this battery overdone hi
boo hoo hoo ha ha ha no no no don't Mele
the air you idiot no dammit you stupid
you so stupid no not me that it is that
is right there
ah
as episodes not going well for me
apparently okay whatever like I'm always
too lowly like a crawl over the way I
don't know how this mic handles me
screaming into it just yet I haven't had
a chance to legitly legitimately scream
in it so hopefully that didn't blow out
your eardrums I'm sure you'd be fine
this is a very nice mom
but I've said enough about that yes yes
markiplier we know your mic is great and
all that okay
what's that sound
sounds like a big monster I need to kill
oh it says mining log planet crack went
smoothly problems planetside temporary
lost contact with call the first rock
ball extracted process for finding
smelted results have exceeded even
octave optimistic initial estimates
normal recovery is around thirty five
percent mineral five percent fossil
sixty percent waste but mineral material
from the first ball was sixty five
percent mineral and zero percent fossil
in line with expectations whew not bad
we've hit a mother lode yeah right your
own yeah okay here here and all yeah
semiconductor um and there's a space
return
who's out there hein bodies don't trust
you now's the time to Mele you scuba
dive ha ok all right what do we got here
big row Wow
that's big talking about
anyway what ah why is that Wow black one
yo hi another one nope not today
come on die so tough nothing tough as me
though anymore what
come on your black ones you should give
me more than ammo jerks
why are the bodies all gathered up
around the door
um
Oh what art music I know
surgical precision that's me that's my
middle name it's I know
hey there we go shoot something it'll
explode
that'll do so
okay um oh okay there's a panel
obviously I'm stupid
um zero gravity yeah it is
um oh wait oh okay
give it up
shoot it there we go kibou
okay
after net percent but
oh man ooh la da da da da da
okay never supposed to do anyway
what what what you want me to go on it
there's kind of big metal things
swinging probably deadly whatever come
on
not quite sure if it wants me to go to
my death oh can I say
like I stasis the big ball of rock but
that did all right I'm just gonna maybe
I can jump ah there we go
okay can I run past you I got a glowy
there we go oh okay
okay hi baby got your baby now welcome
here
yeah give me that Oh what huh oh okay
I'll do that then
link up more of these things shoot you
come on shoot there we go I'm such a
good shot as another one on the other
side just like inside there we go Oh
what the hell get out of here you know
you try not good stomp your face and
your face God my boot is weak strong
with this one okay I got it
whoa hello I got to get back and I got a
jump okay not fit right into the monster
I'll get me a point yeah took you with
me ah I'm gonna monster on me oh yeah
don't yes I carried my monster around
going conduct this I'll look at me
all right I actually got to cut it here
so enjoy this view the monster oh no
it's chicken over my buddy hi thank you
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next one bye bye